Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. It was Wednesday the 2nd of August 1989. 41 year old Marguerite Edwards started the day like any other, making sure her three daughters were up and ready for school. Marguerite was happily married to Ian Edwards, a successful orthodontist with a surgery in Bondi. They lived in a two story house on Victoria Road, Wallara, in Sydney's eastern suburbs. Wallara is an extremely affluent suburb, five kilometres east of Sydney's CBD, a few miles, known for its quiet treeline streets and extremely expensive housing. After getting her daughters organised, Marguerite dropped them off at Ascom School. She then made her way to an aerobics class before doing some shopping at Bondi. She then returned to her Wallara home sometime after midday. Later that afternoon Marguerite's three daughters were waiting. School had finished and they were wondering where mum was. When Marguerite didn't show up to the school that afternoon, it was very unusual. Many of the other parents even commented saying don't worry, your mum is never late. She will be here soon. But she never arrived. The girls next door neighbour Marcia Osborne ended up giving them a lift home. Marcia telling them obviously something important had come up and everything would be fine.
你试过在烧烤上再加烧烤吗？想象一下：新鲜烹制的酥脆调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉，再淋上一层奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来？那你现在就可以去Tim's尝尝。限时供应我们全新的烧烤脆皮鸡肉碗和卷饼。那是1989年8月2日，星期三。41岁的玛格丽特·爱德华兹像往常一样开始了一天，确保她的三个女儿起床并准备好去上学。玛格丽特与伊恩·爱德华兹婚姻幸福，伊恩是一位成功的牙齿矫正医生，在邦迪开了一家诊所。他们住在悉尼东郊沃拉拉维多利亚路上的一栋两层楼房里。沃拉拉是一个极其富裕的郊区，位于悉尼中央商务区以东五公里处，以安静的绿树成荫的街道和极其昂贵的住房而闻名。安顿好女儿们后，玛格丽特送她们去了阿斯科姆学校。然后她去上了一节健美操课，之后在邦迪买了一些东西。中午过后不久，她回到了沃拉拉的家中。那天下午晚些时候，玛格丽特的三个女儿在等待。学校放学了，她们想知道妈妈在哪里。玛格丽特那天下午没有出现在学校，这非常不寻常。许多其他家长甚至评论说，别担心，你妈妈从不迟到。她很快就会到的。但她一直没有出现。隔壁邻居玛西娅·奥斯本最终开车送她们回家。玛西娅告诉她们，显然是有什么重要的事情耽搁了，一切都会好起来的。
But the girls had a feeling something wasn't right. When they got home, they saw Marguerite's car parked in the driveway. They walked inside and called out for their mum, but got no reply. As they slowly made their way to the kitchen, they saw a pool of blood on the floor, blood on the bench, blood on the fridge and that chairs had been knocked over. Realising something was horribly wrong, Marcia grabbed the girls and said let's get out of here, I'll ring the police. Police arrived soon after and found Marguerite's body upstairs, laying in her walk-in wardrobe, connected to the main bedroom. She had extensive head injuries and one of Ian's neck ties was wrapped around her neck. Another neck tie had been used to gag her. Detectives and specialist crime scene police were immediately called in and a forensic examination was conducted. No fingerprints were found, however they did find a towel with blood stains on it. It was 1989 and DNA analysis had only started in NSW that year. So there was no large database to compare the sample to and the nature of the testing was very different to what exists today. However it was possible that it would come in useful in the future to compare to a suspect if one was ever identified. It was clear from the forensic examination that the initial attack occurred downstairs, after which Marguerite was taken upstairs to the bedroom.
但女孩们有一种不祥的预感。当她们回到家时，看到玛格丽特的车停在车道上。她们走进屋里，大声呼唤妈妈，但没有得到回应。当她们慢慢走向厨房时，看到地板上有一滩血，长凳上有血，冰箱上有血，椅子也被撞倒了。意识到出了大事，玛西娅抓住女孩们说，我们离开这里，我去报警。警察很快赶到，在主卧室相连的步入式衣橱里发现了玛格丽特的尸体。她头部受了重伤，脖子上缠着伊恩的一条领带。另一条领带被用来堵住她的嘴。侦探和专门的犯罪现场警察立即被召集，并进行了法医检查。没有发现指纹，但他们确实发现了一条沾有血迹的毛巾。那是1989年，DNA分析那一年才在新南威尔士州开始。因此，没有大型数据库来比对样本，而且测试的性质与今天存在很大差异。然而，如果将来确定了嫌疑人，它可能会派上用场。从法医检查中可以清楚地看出，最初的袭击发生在楼下，之后玛格丽特被带到了楼上的卧室。
She was struck to the head repeatedly with what the forensic pathologist believed was a small hammer or similar tool. The injuries were extensive, causing a fractured skull and brain damage. But the cause of death was strangulation. There was no sign of forced entry to the house. Did Marguerite know her killer and let them in? When they retraced Marguerite's steps they found that she attended an aerobics class between 10.30am and 11.30am at the nearby suburb of Bondi. She was then seen shopping also at Bondi around midday. So that raised the possibility of another theory. Marguerite was known to leave the door open while she was bringing in the shopping, was her killer waiting and simply walked in behind her. Two witnesses were identified early on, both heard screams coming from the house. One was a building surveyor who looked in the direction of the house when he heard the screams, but when he didn't see anything he got in his car and drove off.
她的头部被反复击打，法医病理学家认为凶器是一把小锤子或类似的工具。伤势严重，导致颅骨骨折和脑损伤。但死因是勒死。房子没有强行闯入的迹象。玛格丽特认识凶手并让他们进来的吗？当他们重溯玛格丽特的行踪时，发现她在上午10点30分到11点30分之间在附近的邦迪郊区参加了健美操课。中午左右，她又被看到在邦迪购物。这引发了另一种理论的可能性。众所周知，玛格丽特在搬运购物时会把门开着，是不是凶手在等她，然后直接跟在她身后走了进去？早期确定了两名目击者，他们都听到了从房子里传来的尖叫声。其中一人是一名建筑测量师，他听到尖叫声时朝房子的方向看去，但什么也没看到，于是上了车开车走了。
The second was a woman who was walking past the house with her child. She heard screams about 1.30pm but decided not to report it as she believed it to be just another domestic. She kept walking completely ignoring what she had heard. When Ian asked the police if he could have Marguerite's jewellery back, there was no jewellery to give him. She regularly wore a diamond ring and a watch, but the killer had taken it. The ring alone was worth $20,000. It looked like a robbery had gone wrong. Marguerite had no enemies, so it was the only thing that seemed to make sense. It made even more sense when police learnt that extensive renovations had been carried out in the family home over the last few years. Ian wasn't able to offer much assistance with exactly who was hired, as Marguerite handled all of that while he was at work. So did one of the tradesmen like what he saw inside the house and decide to come back.
第二个人是一位带着孩子路过房子的妇女。她在下午1点30分左右听到了尖叫声，但决定不报告，因为她认为这只是另一场家庭纠纷。她继续走，完全无视了她所听到的。当伊恩问警察他是否可以拿回玛格丽特的珠宝时，没有珠宝可以给他。她经常戴着一枚钻戒和一块手表，但凶手把它们拿走了。仅那枚戒指就价值2万美元。看起来像是一起抢劫案出了差错。玛格丽特没有敌人，所以这是唯一看起来说得通的事情。当警察得知过去几年家里进行了大规模翻修时，这似乎更说得通了。伊恩无法提供关于到底雇了谁的太多帮助，因为他在工作时，玛格丽特处理了所有这些事情。那么，是不是其中一个技工看中了房子里的东西，决定回来呢？
It seemed to fit when you think about the forensic pathologist stating the weapon used looked to be a small hammer or similar tool. Police felt like they might be onto something. There were no records kept of what tradesmen attended, so police got to work questioning as many of them as they could. Builders, carpenters, painters, tillers, plumbers. It all amounted to nothing though. They never tracked down anyone who had completed work in the Edwards home. As good as the theory looked, it wasn't gaining any momentum. Police even spent days searching every hardware store they could find, trying to find a hammer or similar tool that could have inflicted the injuries. It was hoped that if they could identify the tool, it would help narrow down the search for the tradesmen.
当你想到法医病理学家说使用的武器看起来像是一把小锤子或类似的工具时，这似乎很吻合。警察觉得他们可能发现了什么。没有记录显示哪些技工来过，所以警察开始尽可能多地询问他们。建筑商、木匠、油漆工、瓦工、水管工。但这一切都一无所获。他们从未追踪到任何在爱德华兹家完成过工作的人。尽管这个理论看起来不错，但它并没有获得任何进展。警察甚至花了几天时间搜查了他们能找到的每一家五金店，试图找到一把可能造成伤害的锤子或类似工具。人们希望如果他们能确定工具，将有助于缩小对技工的搜寻范围。
But that also amounted to nothing. They couldn't find anything that matched. Ian made an emotional appeal to the media, asking anybody with information to come forward. Photos of the stolen jewellery were also released to the media, in the hope that somebody would recognise them and they would turn up. They were expensive, unique pieces. But this didn't get the police anywhere either. As much as they liked the robbery theory, they couldn't ignore the fact that the majority of murders are committed by somebody close to the victim. Everything suggested Ian and Marguerite were in a loving marriage, with no problems at all. Ian was quoted as saying,
但这同样一无所获。他们找不到任何匹配的东西。伊恩向媒体发出感人呼吁，请求任何有信息的人站出来。被盗珠宝的照片也被发布给媒体，希望有人能认出它们，它们会出现。它们是昂贵、独特的物品。但这也没有让警察取得任何进展。尽管他们喜欢抢劫理论，但他们不能忽视大多数谋杀案都是由受害者身边的人犯下的这一事实。一切都表明伊恩和玛格丽特婚姻美满，没有任何问题。伊恩曾说：
To my knowledge, my wife had no enemies. We had a perfect relationship for the 20 years of our marriage, and we were very much in love. We have three children, and we are very close and happy family. Ian went on to describe Marguerite as happy, graceful, always smiling, always laughing, and never angry. Saying their marriage was perfect bliss. And Ian had an alibi. He was at work the whole day. But it was when police started to look a bit closer, they realised that maybe Ian's alibi wasn't as solid as it initially seemed. Ian's orthodontic surgery was 2.2 kilometres away from the family home, roughly 1.3 miles. Through their investigation, they learnt that Ian was supposed to go home and have lunch with Marguerite the day she was killed.
据我所知，我妻子没有敌人。在我们20年的婚姻中，我们有着完美的关系，我们非常相爱。我们有三个孩子，我们是一个非常亲密和幸福的家庭。伊恩继续描述玛格丽特快乐、优雅，总是微笑，总是大笑，从不生气。说他们的婚姻是完美的幸福。而且伊恩有不在场证明。他整天都在工作。但当警察开始仔细观察时，他们意识到伊恩的不在场证明可能并不像最初看起来那么稳固。伊恩的牙齿矫正诊所距离家2.2公里，大约1.3英里。通过调查，他们得知伊恩本应在玛格丽特被杀那天回家和她一起吃午饭。
But he says he got too busy and had to cancel. Instead, he sent his nurse out to buy him a sandwich. The nurse was out for 25 minutes, and Ian didn't have any patients during that time. So there was a 25 minute window that Ian didn't have an alibi for. Ian was a fit man, who was known to regularly go for a run during his lunch break. Police were able to confirm that his car never left the parking lot of his surgery. Could he have run home, killed Marguerite, and made it back to his surgery in time? Two detectives completed the challenge, running from Ian's surgery to his house, and then back again. Factoring in the time it would have taken to commit the murder.
但他说是他太忙了，不得不取消。相反，他派他的护士出去给他买三明治。护士出去了25分钟，伊恩在那段时间里没有病人。所以有一个25分钟的窗口期，伊恩没有不在场证明。伊恩是一个身体健康的人，众所周知他经常在午休时间跑步。警察能够确认他的车从未离开过诊所的停车场。他能跑回家，杀了玛格丽特，然后及时赶回诊所吗？两名侦探完成了挑战，从伊恩的诊所跑到他家，然后再跑回来。考虑到实施谋杀所需的时间。
And the fact Ian was definitely back seeing a patient straight after lunch, showing no signs he had just been for a run. Police were able to rule it out. They kept an open mind. Ian wasn't ruled out completely, but the idea he physically had anything to do with it was extremely doubtful. That pretty much left them back to square one. The tradesman theory had gotten them nowhere, and Ian didn't look likely. He didn't stop the public's opinion though. Ian felt the suspicious eyes on him everywhere he went. His business partner of 17 years suddenly ended their relationship.
以及伊恩午饭后确实立即回来见病人，没有任何迹象表明他刚跑过步的事实。警察能够排除这种可能性。他们保持开放的心态。伊恩并没有被完全排除，但他与此事有身体接触的想法极其令人怀疑。这几乎让他们回到了原点。技工理论让他们一无所获，伊恩看起来也不太可能。但这并没有阻止公众的舆论。伊恩感到他所到之处都有怀疑的目光。他合作了17年的商业伙伴突然结束了他们的关系。
And people in the area even held dinner parties to sit around and discuss theories about how Ian could have pulled it off. Police freely admitted the investigation had stalled, and it was going cold. It was nine months later, in May 1990, that a $50,000 reward was offered for any information that led to the case being solved. Not only that, the government took the step of offering a pardon to any person who may have assisted, so long as they weren't directly involved in the killing. Police did get plenty of calls and tips and names to check out, but none of it was useful. The case continued to run cold, and it looked destined to remain on the unsolved shelf. But on the 23rd of August 1991, they got the break they were looking for. 35 year old Christopher Anthony Lorenzo was in Long Bay Jail in Sydney, waiting to be sentenced on several armed robbery charges.
该地区的人们甚至举行晚宴，坐在一起讨论伊恩是如何做到的理论。警察坦率地承认调查已经停滞，并且正在变冷。九个月后，即1990年5月，悬赏5万美元征集任何导致案件破获的信息。不仅如此，政府还采取了步骤，向任何可能提供协助的人提供赦免，只要他们没有直接参与杀人。警察确实接到了很多电话、线索和名字需要核实，但都没有用。案件继续变冷，看起来注定要留在未破案件的架子上。但在1991年8月23日，他们得到了他们一直在寻找的突破。35岁的克里斯托弗·安东尼·洛伦佐当时在悉尼的长湾监狱，等待因多项武装抢劫指控被判刑。
Lorenzo was born in Cape Town, South Africa, on the 2nd of July 1956. He had a history of drug use, break-ins and armed robberies. Lorenzo had gotten the word out he had information that would be of interest to homicide detectives. They paid him a visit and became very interested in what he had to say when he told them he knew who killed the dentist's wife in Wallara. Prison inmates generally don't give information to police out of the kindness of their heart. There is always a motive, and Lorenzo was no different. He wanted to be moved to a jail that was a bit easier to do time than Long Bay, and he wanted police to have a word to the judges so he could get a reduced sentence for his armed robbery charges.
洛伦佐于1956年7月2日出生在南非开普敦。他有吸毒、入室盗窃和武装抢劫的历史。洛伦佐放出话来，说他有凶杀案侦探会感兴趣的信息。他们拜访了他，当他告诉他们他知道是谁杀了沃拉拉的牙医妻子时，他们变得非常感兴趣。监狱囚犯通常不会出于好心向警察提供信息。总是有动机的，洛伦佐也不例外。他想被转移到一个比长湾更容易服刑的监狱，他希望警察能跟法官说句话，这样他就能减轻武装抢劫指控的刑期。
He was facing a five year sentence, but he didn't want to do that long. Lorenzo had made a handwritten statement for police, detailing everything he knew about Marguerite's murder. This was his story. The day Marguerite was murdered, Lorenzo was at a local pub having lunch and enjoying a few beers. His friend David Anelzac approached him and wanted to borrow his car. It was actually Lorenzo's girlfriend's car, but he agreed. When Anelzac returned the car a few hours later, there was blood in it, and blood on Anelzac himself. Lorenzo asked him what the fuck happened.
他面临五年刑期，但他不想服刑那么久。洛伦佐为警察写了一份手写声明，详细说明了他所知道的关于玛格丽特谋杀案的一切。这就是他的故事。玛格丽特被谋杀的那天，洛伦佐在当地一家酒吧吃午饭，喝了几杯啤酒。他的朋友大卫·阿内尔扎克走近他，想借他的车。其实那是洛伦佐女朋友的车，但他同意了。当阿内尔扎克几个小时后还车时，车里有血，阿内尔扎克自己身上也有血。洛伦佐问他到底发生了什么事。
Anelzac told him he broke into a house, but it went wrong. A woman saw him and started screaming, so he had to silence her. Anelzac pointed out a replica pistol in the boot and told Lorenzo to drown it. But Lorenzo didn't get rid of the gun. He decided to keep it for insurance. While he was cleaning up the blood in the car, he found an expensive looking gold bracelet underneath one of the seats. He decided to keep that too, and he later gave it to his girlfriend. Police believed Lorenzo's story had merit. Anelzac was well-known to them.
阿内尔扎克告诉他，他闯入了一所房子，但出了差错。一个女人看到了他并开始尖叫，所以他不得不让她闭嘴。阿内尔扎克指着后备箱里的一把仿制手枪，告诉洛伦佐把它淹死。但洛伦佐没有处理掉那把枪。他决定留着它作为保险。当他在清理车里的血迹时，他在座位下面发现了一个看起来很昂贵的金手镯。他决定也留着它，后来把它给了他的女朋友。警察认为洛伦佐的故事有价值。阿内尔扎克是他们熟知的人。
At the time of Marguerite's murder, he wasn't long out of prison after doing time for a manslaughter charge. But they needed to do some background work to try and verify the story. Lorenzo said he could actually help them with that. He could give police the replica pistol that Anelzac told him to get rid of. In his words, The gun has been right under your nose for years. The armed hold up boys have got it. It's a police exhibit.
在玛格丽特被谋杀时，他因过失杀人罪服刑后刚出狱不久。但他们需要做一些背景工作来试图核实这个故事。洛伦佐说他实际上可以帮助他们。他可以给警察阿内尔扎克告诉他处理掉的那把仿制手枪。用他的话说，这把枪多年来一直就在你们眼皮底下。武装抢劫组的人有它。它是警方的证物。
When Lorenzo was arrested for the armed robberies, police searched his house and took a number of items, including a replica pistol. As Lorenzo's charges weren't finalized and he was still waiting to be sentenced, the replica pistol was still locked away in police evidence. The pistol was immediately sent to forensics to see if they could link it to the murder. And they could. Marguerite's head injuries were a match to the wrist sight on the replica pistol. So the weapon used wasn't a small hammer or similar tool as previously thought. Not only that, the pistol tested positive for blood.
当洛伦佐因武装抢劫被捕时，警察搜查了他的房子并拿走了一些物品，包括一把仿制手枪。由于洛伦佐的指控尚未最终确定，他还在等待判刑，所以仿制手枪仍被锁在警方证据中。手枪立即被送往法医部门，看看他们是否能将其与谋杀案联系起来。他们做到了。玛格丽特的头部伤口与仿制手枪上的准星相符。所以使用的武器并不是之前认为的小锤子或类似工具。不仅如此，手枪的血迹检测呈阳性。
They also managed to track down Lorenzo's girlfriend, Josephine Tapani. Not only did she confirm Lorenzo's story, but she still had the bracelet. It was a bracelet that Marguerite had custom made. Nobody had realized it was missing until Lorenzo gave his story to police. Josephine said it was Lorenzo who actually wore it around initially, but he said it was too tight for him, so he ended up giving it to her. His story was that somebody had given it to him at a takeaway shop in Surrey Hills, a suburb not too far away from Wallara.
他们还设法追踪到了洛伦佐的女朋友约瑟芬·塔帕尼。她不仅证实了洛伦佐的故事，而且她仍然拥有那个手镯。那是玛格丽特定制的手镯。直到洛伦佐向警察讲述他的故事，没有人意识到它不见了。约瑟芬说，最初确实是洛伦佐戴着它，但他说对他来说太紧了，所以他最终把它给了她。他的故事是，有人在萨里山的一家外卖店给了他，萨里山是一个离沃拉拉不太远的郊区。
Lorenzo seemed genuine and authentic, and now there was some evidence to back up what he was saying. It looked like he was telling the truth, and the lure of a reduced sentence and a softer prison to do his time was enough for him to give up his friend. David Anelzark became the prime suspect. Lorenzo hadn't had any contact with Anelzark for a little while, so there was no suspicion when police put their plan into action. They took Lorenzo out of jail and placed him into a motel room at Bondi, where they had installed both video and audio surveillance.
洛伦佐看起来真诚且真实，现在有一些证据支持他所说的话。看起来他在说实话，而减轻刑期和去一个更轻松的监狱服刑的诱惑足以让他出卖他的朋友。大卫·阿内尔扎克成了头号嫌疑人。洛伦佐有一段时间没有和阿内尔扎克联系了，所以当警察实施他们的计划时，没有任何怀疑。他们把洛伦佐从监狱里带出来，安置在邦迪的一家汽车旅馆房间里，在那里他们安装了视频和音频监控。
Police were monitoring in the next room. The plan was simple. Lorenzo would lure his old buddy to the motel and get him talking about the murder of Marguerite. As much as they believed Lorenzo was willing to help, they didn't completely trust him. They couldn't handcuff him, that would give the game away. So what they did was put a plaster cast on his leg, making it impossible for him to run or to drive. Just as a bit of insurance, so he wasn't tempted to try and escape. Anelzark arrived as planned, and Lorenzo got to work.
警察在隔壁房间监控。计划很简单。洛伦佐会把他的老朋友引诱到汽车旅馆，让他谈论玛格丽特的谋杀案。尽管他们相信洛伦佐愿意帮忙，但他们并不完全信任他。他们不能给他戴上手铐，那会泄露秘密。所以他们做的是在他的腿上打了一个石膏，使他不可能跑步或开车。只是作为一点保险，这样他就不会试图逃跑。阿内尔扎克按计划到达，洛伦佐开始行动。
He was successful in getting Anelzark talking. They went at it for three hours. Unfortunately, not one second of the conversation had anything to do with the murder of Marguerite Edwards. Lorenzo didn't bring it up at all, and Anelzark wasn't volunteering anything. Lorenzo failed miserably. He acknowledged his failure and apologized, saying he was scared and he couldn't work out how to bring the murder up without making it obvious. But the conversation didn't sit right with detectives. It led them to become suspicious of what exactly his motive was.
他成功地让阿内尔扎克开口了。他们谈了三个小时。不幸的是，谈话中没有一秒钟与玛格丽特·爱德华兹的谋杀案有关。洛伦佐根本没有提起，阿内尔扎克也没有主动说出任何事情。洛伦佐惨败。他承认了自己的失败并道歉，说他很害怕，不知道如何在不明显的情况下提起谋杀案。但谈话让侦探们觉得不对劲。这导致他们开始怀疑他的动机到底是什么。
They decided to go back and have a closer look at that handwritten statement he gave them. There just so happened to be a world-renowned document profiler in Sydney at the time. He was getting ready to fly back to the USA, but detectives just called him in time at the airport. They handed him Lorenzo's statement, along with the background of the case. A few weeks later, detectives received a detailed 30-page report analyzing Lorenzo's statement. Every word and every phrase was looked at, as was the way Lorenzo's story changed from the first to the second person. The conclusion? If Christopher Lorenzo wasn't the murderer, he was at the very least present when the murder was committed.
他们决定回去仔细看看他给他们的那份手写声明。当时悉尼正好有一位世界知名的文件分析专家。他正准备飞回美国，但侦探们在机场及时叫住了他。他们把洛伦佐的声明连同案件背景交给了他。几周后，侦探们收到了一份详细的30页报告，分析了洛伦佐的声明。每一个字和每一个短语都被审视，洛伦佐的故事从第一人称到第二人称的转换方式也是如此。结论是什么？如果克里斯托弗·洛伦佐不是凶手，他至少在谋杀发生时在场。
Police had a new number one suspect. Lorenzo had a unique blood type found in just 3% of the population. He matched the blood type found on the towel at the crime scene. Given that Lorenzo was cooperating with police on a murder investigation, he had been moved to a special part of the jail reserved for police informants. The rats, the snitches, as they are commonly known. He became a little too friendly with his cellmate, whose identity is protected. But he was given the nickname Mr Smith.
警察有了一个新的头号嫌疑人。洛伦佐有一种独特的血型，仅存在于3%的人口中。他与犯罪现场毛巾上发现的血型相符。鉴于洛伦佐正在配合警方进行谋杀调查，他被转移到了监狱中专门为警方线人保留的一个特殊区域。也就是通常所说的老鼠、告密者。他与他的狱友变得太亲近了，狱友的身份受到保护。但他被起了个绰号叫史密斯先生。
Lorenzo couldn't help but brag how he had put one over the police. He obviously forgot what part of the jail he was in, because Mr Smith notified the police, and they quickly arranged for him to wear a wire. On the 19th of June 1992, Smith got him talking again. Lorenzo claimed there were actually two other men present during the murder, and they were all off their faces on heroin. Lorenzo said, the woman came home and John pointed the gun at her, and she started screaming. He grabbed her and started hitting her in the head with the butt of the pistol until she shut up.
洛伦佐忍不住吹嘘他是如何欺骗警察的。他显然忘记了他在监狱的哪个部分，因为史密斯先生通知了警察，他们很快安排他戴上窃听器。1992年6月19日，史密斯再次让他开口。洛伦佐声称谋杀时实际上还有另外两名男子在场，他们都吸食了海洛因。洛伦佐说，那个女人回家了，约翰用枪指着她，她开始尖叫。他抓住她，开始用手枪柄猛击她的头部，直到她闭嘴。
See what sparked him off was her screaming, because he told her to shut up. He pointed the gun at her. She screamed, and she kept screaming. The more he hit her, the more she screamed. Smith, so he would have hit her in a frenzy. Yeah, because she was screaming. Smith, so she was screaming and he's baster in the head. Lorenzo, and she wouldn't stop screaming.
看，让她发火的是她的尖叫，因为他叫她闭嘴。他用枪指着她。她尖叫，她一直尖叫。他打得越狠，她尖叫得越厉害。史密斯，所以他是在疯狂中打了她。是的，因为她在尖叫。史密斯，所以她在尖叫，他猛击她的头。洛伦佐，她就是不停地尖叫。
Smith, why did he hit her? He could have put his hand over her mouth. Lorenzo, we had just had a shot of smack before going there, and John just panicked and started hitting her in the head. Then she was taken upstairs to her bedroom. She came to and started screaming again. John hit her in the head a few more times. She kept screaming, so this other guy grabbed the tie and strangled her with it, and left her lying in the wardrobe.
史密斯，他为什么要打她？他本可以把手捂在她的嘴上。洛伦佐，我们在去那里之前刚吸了一口海洛因，约翰只是惊慌失措，开始猛击她的头部。然后她被带到楼上的卧室。她醒过来，又开始尖叫。约翰又打了她头几下。她一直尖叫，所以这个家伙抓起领带勒死了她，把她留在衣橱里。
Smith, why did he strangle her? Lorenzo, because she could identify the other guy. This next passage will give you an idea of who the other guy was. Smith, is Dr. Edwards well off? Lorenzo. When I did the tiling at their house, I used their phone so I could check out the house. They were loaded. The tradesman theory was right all along.
史密斯，他为什么要勒死她？洛伦佐，因为她能认出那个家伙。接下来的这段话会让你知道那个家伙是谁。史密斯，爱德华兹医生很有钱吗？洛伦佐。当我在他们家做瓷砖工作时，我用了他们的电话，这样我就可以查看房子。他们很有钱。技工理论一直都是对的。
Christopher Lorenzo had been to the Edwards home during their renovations. He had completed tiling work there over a number of days in September 1998, about one year before the murder. Police were unaware of that before Lorenzo's taped conversation. Lorenzo was trying to say there were other people involved, so it was like a confession, but he couldn't come out and directly say it was just him. So he described it as someone else who attacked her. The guy who was scared Marguerite could identify him was of course Lorenzo.
克里斯托弗·洛伦佐在翻修期间去过爱德华兹家。他在1998年9月，即谋杀案发生前大约一年，在那里完成了几天的瓷砖工作。在洛伦佐的录音谈话之前，警察并不知道这一点。洛伦佐试图说还有其他人参与，所以这就像是一种供认，但他不能直接说只有他一个人。所以他把它描述为攻击她的另一个人。那个害怕玛格丽特能认出他的家伙当然就是洛伦佐。
He was talking about himself. Lorenzo then bragged how he stole Marguerite's watch, ring and bracelet. Smith asked him if he had much trouble getting the ring off. Lorenzo said, No, none, none. But I mean she had blood all over her hands, over her head. Why do you think I couldn't sleep for six months? Smith, did you have to turn her over or anything like that to get the rings?
他在谈论自己。洛伦佐随后吹嘘他是如何偷走玛格丽特的手表、戒指和手镯的。史密斯问他摘下戒指是否有困难。洛伦佐说，不，没有，没有。但我的意思是她手上、头上全是血。你以为我为什么六个月睡不着觉？史密斯，你必须把她翻过来或者做类似的事情来拿戒指吗？
Lorenzo. No, no, no, no. She was just laying there with... Her hands were tied behind her back, so it was easy. So she was laying face down. Yeah, it was easy. It wasn't hard. Then Lorenzo started talking about the bracelet. They could never charge anybody with that.
洛伦佐。不，不，不，不。她就躺在那里……她的手被绑在背后，所以很容易。所以她是脸朝下躺着的。是的，很容易。一点也不难。然后洛伦佐开始谈论手镯。他们永远无法以此指控任何人。
It wasn't reported as missing from the scene of the crime. I could have sold on at any time I was at that house. You know what I mean? When I was toiling it. That's why there's been nothing ever on this bracelet. Smith then asked, Did anybody who went into the house cut themselves, leave any blood behind? Anything that might have been mixed with her blood? You said you cut your hand.
它没有被报告为从犯罪现场丢失。我随时可以在我在那所房子里的时候卖掉它。你知道我的意思吗？当我在铺瓷砖的时候。这就是为什么这个手镯一直没有任何线索。史密斯接着问，任何进入房子的人有没有割伤自己，留下任何血迹？有没有什么可能和她的血混在一起？你说你割伤了手。
Lorenzo, yeah. Smith, could you have dropped any blood inside the house? Lorenzo. The only thing in the place was on the tail. Where was the tail used? To wipe down the fucking handles and shit. Lorenzo was so confident because he really believed in his alibi that he was at the pub having lunch at the time of the murder, and he never left.
洛伦佐，是的。史密斯，你有没有在房子里滴过血？洛伦佐。那个地方唯一的东西是在毛巾上。毛巾是用在哪里？用来擦掉该死的把手之类的东西。洛伦佐如此自信，因为他真的相信他在谋杀时在酒吧吃午饭的不在场证明，而且他从未离开过。
He didn't think police would ever be able to crack it. My alibi, Smith, was three years ago. No one's going to even remember behind the pub. But no one's going to remember me, not being in that pub. So how long have we gone from the pub? Yeah. Nothing, that's because cop just can't present anything without one alibi. Just in case you had trouble picking that up.
他不认为警察能破解它。我的不在场证明，史密斯，是三年前的事了。没有人会记得酒吧后面。但没有人会记得我不在那个酒吧。所以我们离开酒吧多久了？是的。什么都没有，那是因为警察没有不在场证明就无法提出任何东西。以防你听不清楚。
My alibi is sweet. It was three years ago. No one's going to even remember me in the pub. But no one's going to remember me not being in that pub. So how long were you gone from the pub? An hour, something like that, three quarters of an hour. Cop just can't prove anything. Lorenzo saw how well off the Abud's looked and decided to go back and steal from them. Breaking in using a copied key he had from when he was tiling.
我的不在场证明很完美。那是三年前的事了。没有人会记得我在酒吧。但没有人会记得我不在那个酒吧。所以你离开酒吧多久了？一个小时左右，四分之三小时。警察根本证明不了什么。洛伦佐看到阿布德一家看起来很有钱，决定回去偷他们。用他铺瓷砖时复制的钥匙闯入。
That's why there was no sign of forced entry. But Margarite came home while he was there. Instead of running away, he decided to kill her. Lorenzo's attempt to pin a murder he had committed onto somebody else in order to have his jail time reduced backfired in a big way. On the 7th of July 1992, Lorenzo was taken from Long Bay Jail to a nearby police station where he was interviewed and charged with the murder of Margarite Abud's.
这就是为什么没有强行闯入的迹象。但玛格丽特在他还在的时候回家了。他没有逃跑，而是决定杀了她。洛伦佐试图将他犯下的谋杀案嫁祸给别人以减轻刑期的企图以惨败告终。1992年7月7日，洛伦佐被从长湾监狱带到附近的警察局，在那里他接受了审讯，并被指控谋杀玛格丽特·阿布德。
He pleaded not guilty and his trial was held in the Supreme Court and commenced in September 1993. Lorenzo wasn't done with his old mate David Anelzark either. Ignoring the conversation that had been recorded, he went back to his original story that he gave police, that Anelzark borrowed his car and he was just at the pub the whole time. The recorded conversation being explained away is just bragging to his cellmate, trying to make himself look good.
他不认罪，他的审判在最高法院举行，并于1993年9月开始。洛伦佐也没有放过他的老朋友大卫·阿内尔扎克。忽略了被录下的谈话，他回到了他最初给警察的故事，即阿内尔扎克借了他的车，而他一直都在酒吧。录下的谈话被解释为只是在狱友面前吹牛，试图让自己看起来很厉害。
This time he added an explanation for his blood being at the scene. That was that Anelzark made him go to the house after the murder to wipe it down for fingerprints and it was while wiping the place down, he cut himself. The trial lasted four weeks. They took the jury just over three hours to reach their verdict. Guilty. Ian Edwards had this to say after the verdict came through.
这一次，他为他的血出现在现场增加了一个解释。那就是阿内尔扎克在谋杀后强迫他去房子里擦掉指纹，正是在擦拭现场时，他割伤了自己。审判持续了四个星期。陪审团花了三个多小时才达成裁决。有罪。伊恩·爱德华兹在裁决出来后说了这样的话。
We spent four weeks in there listening to how somebody bashed and strangled her to death. We're glad that it's finished technically for us and that somebody has been convicted of the crime. We don't hate Lorenzo in any way. He did what he did and that was his mistake and he'll now have the rest of his life, I think, to think about it in jail. He could have at least had the courage to maybe admit what he did
我们在那里花了四个星期听别人是如何把她打死并勒死的。我们很高兴它在技术上对我们来说结束了，并且有人被判犯有该罪行。我们绝不恨洛伦佐。他做了他所做的事，那是他的错误，我想他余生将在监狱里思考这件事。他至少可以有勇气承认他做了什么
and I think it would have been a lot easier on everybody concerned including himself. What he was trying to do was tell the world what he did. Only he didn't have the courage to say he did it. He used somebody else as the medium of relieving his own conscience. The judge said to Lorenzo it was a cowardly and brutal attack. A murder in her own home in broad daylight of a woman going about her own business who had done you no harm. Knowing that Marguerite would be able to identify him as the tyler from the year before,
我想这对包括他自己在内的所有相关人员来说都会容易得多。他试图做的是告诉世界他做了什么。只是他没有勇气说他做了。他利用别人作为减轻自己良心的媒介。法官对洛伦佐说，这是一次懦弱而残忍的袭击。在光天化日之下，在自己家中谋杀了一名正在做自己事情、没有伤害过你的妇女。知道玛格丽特能认出他是前一年的瓦工，
he decided to kill her. Lorenzo was sentenced on the 26th of November 1993. He received a sentence of 22 years and 6 months with a non-parole period of 17 years. But Lorenzo had since been sentenced on the armed robbery charges and they didn't expire until October 1996 so his sentence for the murder didn't start until then meaning he would be eligible to be released in 2013.
他决定杀了她。洛伦佐于1993年11月26日被判刑。他被判处22年零6个月的刑期，不得假释期为17年。但洛伦佐此后因武装抢劫指控被判刑，直到1996年10月才到期，所以他的谋杀刑期从那时才开始，这意味着他有资格在2013年获释。
Luckily instead of keeping his mouth shut and doing his five-year sentence for armed robbery Lorenzo decided to try and pin a murder on a friend to get out early. In doing so he implicated himself and the case was able to be solved. Instead of five he would now be in jail for at least 22 years. On the 30th of November 2010 Lorenzo made a visit to the prison doctor complaining that he had been feeling unwell for a while. Tests revealed he was suffering from advanced stages of leukemia.
幸运的是，洛伦佐没有闭嘴并服完他的五年武装抢劫刑期，而是决定试图将谋杀案嫁祸给朋友以提前出狱。在此过程中，他牵连了自己，案件得以破获。他现在不仅要服刑五年，还要在监狱里至少待22年。2010年11月30日，洛伦佐去监狱医生那里看病，抱怨他感觉不舒服已经有一段时间了。检查显示他患有晚期白血病。
He was transferred to Prince of Wales Hospital. He died two months later on the 9th of January 2011 aged 54. Two years and nine months before he was eligible for parole. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他被转移到威尔士亲王医院。两个月后，即2011年1月9日，他去世了，享年54岁。在他有资格假释前两年零九个月。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。